miss refute your tailor
I am the GU Mui Pam live on date you are
done interview what will happen
interview an 11 out of you
when people see Lee Perry they're
feeling the skies just soul pouring out
he hits on something that's just magical
we scratch Perry's a magician he's a
madman
he's a music maker he's one of a kind
there's never gonna be one like him
again my work with Lee scratch Perry as
his bandleader he was like an idol of
mine I you I never thought I would meet
the guy didn't even know if he was alive
scratch is kind of like Yoda but he's
also like a child inside an 80 year old
man's body yeah
in many ways I feel like he's
underappreciated he's a guy who has
touched so many people
Bob Marley Paul McCartney The Clash The
Beastie Boys Keith Richards once said
that Lee scratch Perry was the Salvador
Dali of music then I stress you my heart
compels me to know he's young what's on
TV card anyway I get rather Mophie on
this but it really impaired his heart ye
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh I wash my face ah ah
dude it's amazing to see the sky was 80
years old it's just this creative force
of nature he's never without a computer
now he's even said sometimes the
computer is part of him is constantly
reacting to what's around him and
processing it and it comes back out in
one way or another yeah he always talks
about people being either scientists or
or magicians everything I'm doing the
computers and twisting the knob you said
you you're a scientist
this is actually how I wrote the
baseline to this track around me is all
this gear from decades past not unlike
what scratch was using back in Jamaica
in the same way
scratch use the mixing board as an
instrument to shape a new form of music
now we're using the computer to shape a
new form of musical performance so it
allows us to take all this on tour and
take it on stage we're about to give you
the box of mr. Lee scratch Perry how
does everyone feel about that as a sound
all right guys ready I'm fine because
you catch your fire come to catch your
fire
we can't require oftentimes people see
me on stage and they think I'm just EJ
but in fact the one who's very demanding
on the computer we're creating kind of a
new blueprint for live performance
because we're using a combination of
live instruments elements of the music
in the computer and of course elements
of improvisation online every night we
perform it it's different living on
science the nature and spirituality all
coming together and one that's what
anyone can learn from Lee scratch Perry
whether they like his music or not is to
look at the world like a child and never
stop experimenting and pushing your
creativity forward